are you - I mean I can tell you had a
lot of fun making this one yeah yeah
quite the dynamic duo how was it for you
filming with Dave Bautista I mean
incredible like dave was one of the most
favorite people I've worked with you
know he's he's an incredible actor like
it you know the first day I met him and
I did the scene with him like I can just
connect with him there's like no acting
in the scene mmm you're laughing Oh back
stories to us and I remember I mean we
really did we had a great chemistry
reading I learned a little something
about her from day one that she's super
professional and the way I learned that
is because I told her that I was
probably gonna forget my lines and I
asked her if she'd be upset she said she
would I said well that now it's your
responsibility to know your lines of my
lines because I forget my lines but
after our chemistry reads she went out
and and and gave her seal of approval to
her mom she said you know he's pretty
good a good actor no I didn't say pretty
good I said he's amazing after like the
second we left the elevator mom oh my
god Dave isn't like I just yeah we
clicked so do you remember his lines
yeah I did some of them but it's kind of
fun though because then you know the
entire scene that's so true I mean did
you had said that Chloe made you a
better actor how so because she made
sure you remembered your lines she did I
think well you know I think we learned a
bit from each other but I think um what
it is is I had never worked closely with
a child before and Chloe is a special
special gifted child um she is not a
rehearsed actress she's very natural she
can she can just bounce off her cast
mates so it's just uh working where that
didn't feel like I was working with a
child I felt like I was just working
with appear but also she is the most
professional one of the most
professional actresses I've ever worked
with I've ever worked with and she's
always just so prepared it's like she
puts me to shame cuz I'm not prepared at
all you are I'm so not prepared and I
like being a little loosey goosey I like
being flexible in libel and directed and
I'm okay that's just that's my process
that's also what makes this film so fun
there is a looseness to it you know
there's a lot of layers to you got
comedy you have a little bit of action
how would you guys describe this film to
people
well my surprise about you know CIA
agent
who come is said to spy on this family
and the young girl Sophie finds out what
they're spying on them in completely
blackmails I'm into doing things for her
I mean like literally and like in the
trailer I have to say it's just the
surface of the movie there's so much
more like there's even more characters
in a movie that they haven't introduced
yet their whole family and it's just
funny it's a heartwarming yeah that's a
lot of fun and I think there's an
important message about you know fitting
in and iam is placed and and just you
know chosen family sir I really am drawn
to the chosen family theme two films I
mean they're really they hit a personal
note with me so I think that's what
we're really kind of really dive into on
this film and Dave I gotta say that got
you in a pair of ice skates and I don't
mind I actually love dancing yeah yeah
oh and I'm not really not afraid to step
on toes or embarrass myself because I
just like having fun and I don't care if
people are laughing at me if they're
having fun at my expense I'm okay with
it but the ice skating not fun because
it was just I'm not good at it it's
frustrating because I pride myself on
being athletic and when I find something
athletic that I'm not good at really
frustrating to me and also it hurts when
you followed you hurts and I'm also like
it's cold cold
you're falling on cold eyes I'm shocked
they found a pair of skate that fit your
size I know I can't ice skate I do like
ice skating but you know one of the
funny things that when we were filming
that day if so hard that the ice was
starting to melt and it was getting
really watery and I had I tripped like
we weren't rolling or anything and I
tripped
it was so bad and uncomfortable and I
mean we had you we had a map and do you
we had what we had go to the manager
because eventually yes I was just so bad
they had to take the skates off of me
they threw how this big man
yeah and pizza go are directories that
just spin around in circles oh I'll
never say you didn't try I tried
practice I'm just not good at that's
amazing
[Music]